another great example of this in
kentucky a kentucky couple
was just fitted out with ankle monitors
by the local authorities because they
refused to sign a public health
declaration on the coronavirus
so now they're essentially under house
arrest and
they're wearing ankle monitors like
prisoners
they were fitted with this by the hardin
county health department
because the wife tested positive for
coronavirus
and she was willing to be very
responsible with had even though it's
got a what is it
a 99.7 recovery rate
she was going to be very responsible not
leave the house and quarantine
a young woman so she's not really at
great risk here but she refused to sign
one self-quarantined document which
which said that she would not get in an
ambulance
without getting permission from the
public health authorities and her
reasoning made perfect sense she said
you know
if i'm having a heart attack or
something i'm not going to ring up the
public health authorities and get a
permission slip that i'm allowed to go
in an ambulance before i do it i'm just
going to go on an ambulance
so she wasn't going to sign that and so
the authorities
slapped her with an ankle monitor
it's not a scientific question it's a
political question do we want to live in
that sort of police state maybe some
people do
but if you do have the honest debate
don't hide behind this
facade of science with a capital s and a
trademark over
the e led by that wonderful disinteres
disinterested scientist who's smiling at
you by his pool on the cover of in style
and throwing out the first pitch at the
gnats opening day
these are the stakes of politics right
now the left is actually
it's not even like one issue or another
issue or they disagree with you on this
issue it's that they want to take
politics away from you
they don't want you to participate in
politics
they want not just to silence you in the
public arena
they want to silence you you know in the
way that we debate these issues they
want to silence you
in any way contributing to our political
decision-making
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check
out the full episode linked in the
description or download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
you